some Iraqis may view tuk tuks as a
nuisance on three wheels recklessly
weaving in and out of traffic belching
out black smoke and honking all the
while
now during unprecedented protests the
tuk tuks of Tahrir have become a welcome
sight we want a country the important
thing is our country Mohammed me thak is
one of the drivers offering what for
many has become an indispensable service
they're transporting people wounded
during anti-government protests to these
medical tents and nearby hospitals
they're also ferrying volunteer medics
and delivering supplies to Tahrir Square
these tuk-tuk drivers are mostly teenage
boys they've dropped out of school to
help earn money to support their
families Mohammad tells us there's no
place he'd rather be but he's losing
money driving here in Tahrir Square me
thac says people are giving him
donations and helping pay for gas but
drivers are working for free to help
protesters one of the tuk-tuk drivers
was shot in the head and died it made me
more committed to my job I want to be a
martyr I am not afraid of dying on
Friday a medical student was killed
while attempting to treat injured
protesters the people working in these
medical tents spread across the square
and the surrounding area are also
volunteering Muhammad Hadar says each
day he hopes will be the last I'm
motivated by my patriotism for my
country when I see someone in severe
pain it's impossible for me not to help
them I studied and graduated to save
lives meanwhile a kind of civic spirit
is spreading garbage bags have been put
out encouraging people not to litter
protestors are sweeping the streets and
artists are transforming the walls of
this tunnel into a colourful canvas to
express their heartache and their hope
for their country
Natasha Ghanim al jazeera Baghdad